all right so here we have it we're going
to now look at where the selection
stands
according to the projections coming in
from another dollar news agency official
state news agency it does definitely
look like now we can say about president
of Turkey has won this election he's
projected at
52.18 Kamal kalashtarolu the opposition
Challenger
47.82 percent So based on that we can
say that erdogan is the winner he's in
the pole position for these elections
this is quite a development in the
career of
we can continue this discussion with our
guest who we've got standing by live for
us Ali hello good to have you with us
from coach University so
it looks like indeed
we have a winner right well most likely
the official results will also follow
and
what's most striking here is that
erdogan despite the economic crisis
despite the two massive earthquakes
was still able to maintain its basis of
support
uh the character of that support is
clearly
a conservative
and
it means a continuation of policies that
arduan has followed has been following
so the big issue now is if there is
going to be a continuation how are they
going to handle
um the the countries
economic situation and the
foreign policy challenges
so those are the issues now I think we
need to to discuss because the elections
are behind us all right but before we
start looking at that can we ask the
question of
what did it for erdogan yet again as you
said there were some who had their
skepticism because of the earthquake
sure because of the economic situation
what helped him to clench it yet again
well the central Anatolian provinces uh
clearly are looking for his leadership
his charisma
and a following of his
conservative stance and he clearly
reflected that stance in his choices of
alliance members in hudappar and yenidan
refer
clinched that
that vision of a conservative Alliance
together with the nationalists and it's
clearly convinced the central Anatolian
provinces the geography of Turkish
election results appear to be completely
unchanged the the coastal regions and
the the Kurdish dominated Southeast
regions are still supporting
but the rest of the country is
predominantly in in excess of 60 percent
in in many provinces are supporting
erdog and that's an unbeatable uh
unbeatable so what when we've got to ask
also this question what went wrong for
the opposition because they made a big
push to try and break out of those
typical areas you mentioned well they
don't have much credibility obviously
their appeal for nationalists teams came
too little too late in the last few few
days of the campaign in and they relied
predominantly on this
economic crisis idea which did not
convince the voters because they still
looked for a credible charismatic leader
who can actually
provide for an alternative way out of
this economic crisis whereas the
opposition candidate doesn't have
anything to show for for that for
establishing that credibility in the
eyes of the waters and what does this
tell us about the issue of the
Nationalist camp
well the Nationalist Camp was
influential since 2018
but it is split into three four parties
now
and what remains on the opposition Camp
is the weaker players in that camp and
the national section party
I think will continue to
pressure erdogan on issues related to
the Kurdish conflict and relations with
the west and European Union negotiations
we forget but turkey is still in
negotiation phase and we are yet to see
how erdogan is going to shape those
policies without
alleviating the Nationalist
voters and the leadership is this the
end of the road for kamalu this is not
the first time he's gone up against
erdogan in an election
well I should be careful here this is on
all counts
ninth or 10th loss for him
and that's not going to help him
maintain
the party
[Music]
organization together most likely the
the party will go into a fierce
infighting because they were already on
shaky grounds even before these
elections started right and even during
the elections
right after the first round there was a
basic appointing they basically sacked
their campaign managers so the new
campaign managers ran the last 10 days
of the election campaign for them which
is obviously not a winning strategy and
they are suffering because of it all
right thanks so much for talking to us
let's take this now to the presidential
Palace we've got resource standing for
us live there so are they celebrating
tonight
indeed Sami so here there is a
celebration now on the way we see that
now thousands of erdogan supporters
president erdogan supporters are already
gathered in front of the presidential
Palace in Ankara there is a load music
and it's a celebration it's almost like
a festival
um this Festival place now that is
happening in front of the presidential
Palace and they're waiting for the
leaders President erdogan also is
expected to in hours to arrive to Ankara
and to come to the presidential Palace
and Deliver us a speech to his
supporters and also to the nation as
well this is quite unusual because so
far erdogan has been delivering his
speech traditional balcony speech from
the headquarter of his party our party
but this time he decided to do that in
the presidential uh in the presidential
Palace so
it hasn't been an easy race for
president Urban there were lots of oars
there and the economy was definitely
struggling one of the highest inflations
in the world skyrocketing prices and
also on the top of that you have seen a
natural disaster one of the biggest
natural disasters in the industry of the
nation has hit the country between
earthquakes that hit the Southeastern
part of turkey almost around four months
ago 13 million people have been affected
more than 50 000 people have died and
hundreds of thousands injured so tens of
thousands of the buildings were either
collapsed or heavily damaged so despite
all of that he could keep the momentum
and convince the nation that he is still
the best politician that can deliver on
their promises he is he convinced his
supporters that he can rebuild the
country and he convinced the nation that
he can recover the economy on the other
hand for the opposition uh it has been a
failure as of now because despite all of
that odds they failed to convince the
majority of Turks that they are better
than erdogan that they are better in a
better position to to deliver so this
time the hopes were quite high for them
because for the first time we have seen
such a broad Coalition that was formed
in Turkey six parties they came together
with different approaches with different
ideological backgrounds but one of the
main motivation for them was to bring
erdogan down and they came together they
prepared a road map and also they have
chosen the the camel Crystal the
opposition leader as their Unity leader
so the hopes were very very high but in
the first round you have seen that he
received 44.9 personal towards while
erdogan got 49.5 percent of the war so
he led roughly around by Five Points in
the uh in the in the first round and for
the second round another race has
started so it was the first time in the
nation's history that we have witnessed
the second round so there hasn't been
any runoff before in the nation's
history so this is this was the first
one and that's why it was quite
difficult to predict what's how is going
to be the reaction of the waters in this
country as it has never been tested
before but we have seen that erdogan
secured the majority of the wars and
according to presidential sources for
now more than 96 percent of the wars are
counted he is still leading by something
around 52 percent so from now on one of
the main challenge for the opposition is
is definitely going to be how to keep
the unity because there are going to be
lots of criticism system and
particularly for Camel Crystal it is
going to be quite tough because since
assuming the office in 2010 on as the
head of the the leader of the people's
Republican party he has lost several
elections in in this country but this
time as he could Galvanize all of that
support of the opposition behind himself
it was expected that that he could win
so he and his supporters have believed
that however as I said he has failed to
secure the majority of the or or of the
votes in the country so that's why this
election could potentially caused his
political career he wanted to go down in
history as the one who defeated at one
but that didn't happen it didn't happen
in this election as well so for
president Edwin on the other hand is not
going to be easy they're still the
economy is is in a is in a crisis mood
and the disaster area still needs lots
of Investments no also worked still
waiting to be done there so he's going
to face basically the economical crisis
and also to deliver the houses the
accommodations for the people the
hundreds of thousands of people that
have been affected there so that is what
he's also has been by the way through
all of his presidential election
campaign he has been promising on that a
more powerful turkey and a more
assertive turkey in the international
Arena and he was saying that the next
century is going to be tricky as Century
focusing on the mega projects and giving
a dream to the nation so apparently that
rhetoric that narrative has resonated
with his supporters and they have been
convinced to what uh to vote for him so
erdogan has been in politics since four
decades and in the last two decades he
has been the leader of the company
either as prime minister and or as the
the president of the country despite
that long history despite 21 years in
the power in power you have seen that
these elections have showed us that he
is still the most popular politician in
Turkey